ouais alors moi je n'étais pas vraiment
destiné à être un écrivain mais quand
j'étais gamin dans ma chambre avec eux
des encyclopédies et ensuite je me suis
je me suis tourné vers l'informatique et
je suis devenu ingénieur voilà et puis
bon comme à 20 ans tous m'ont écrit
alors moi je me suis mis à écrire
et comme j'ai le goût des choses bien
faites je me suis posé la question
comment faire pour bien écrire et là
j'en ai discuté avec un pote qui lui
écrit depuis longtemps et je dis mais
alors c'est quoi le secret pour bien
écrit et bien avoir un secret et me dit
pour bien écrire il faut lire beaucoup
alors effectivement c'est intéressant de
lire beaucoup parce que déjà ça permet
de s'approprier les mots d'en voir
l'orthographe et de la retenir
mais pas seulement ça permet aussi de
savoir camper un personnage savoir faire
une description savoir avoir du rythme
du style est donc bien écrire si on veut
écrire des romans par exemple il faudra
lire beaucoup de romans si on veut lire
du fantastique
il faut lire beaucoup fantastique si on
veut dire de la terreur il faut lire
beaucoup d'oeuvres de terreur c'est ce
que j'ai fait c'est dans une
bibliothèque j'ai pris au sens de scott
card à retient super intéressante car du
tout lui qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient encore
lovecraft le fraph t'écrivant terreur
reconnu super g tout avaler horta via
butler
j'ai lu obtint la bête l'heure c'est
être super intéressant histoires de
vampires métis qui valent au soleil
c'est extraordinaire et donc j'ai
commencé ensuite à écrire des nouvelles
que j'ai distribué dans mon école et
ensuite à l'âge de 30 ans je rentre en
guadeloupe et la slam blague lance le
slam en guadeloupe par avec josué et
laurence qui lance le slam et non pas de
stars j en comment ça je commence à
m'exprimer à balancer ce que j'ai dans
le coeur et dans le corps qui évidemment
le créole et surtout je commence à
m'exprimer en poésie et là je me rends
compte que la langue de communication ça
suffit pas quand on est en poésie il
faut faire vivre les choses il faut
faire vivre des émotions il faut faire
ressentir des choses aux gens
donc il faut créer il faut utiliser la
langue de métaphores il faut absolument
trouver une façon d'évoquer une façon
d'invoquer plutôt que de désigner
et donc voilà donc jeu
travail à ça et au bout d'un moment
l'espace du slam l'espace de la poésie
ses textes courts ne me suffisait pas
pour pouvoir créer ce que j'avais envie
de créer
et là je me dis je vais m'attaquer au
roman et du coup je me souviens des
conseils de mon pote pour bien écrire il
faut lire au cou je m'énerve
y'a pas au 21e siècle il ya tué dans une
librairie je ne trouve pas de rhume en
oubliant que possible des gens ont fait
des trucs tient effectivement il ya le
sport pigeon est sûr qu'on fait des
textes longs mais rien est publié et
c'est là que je me rends compte que le
corps n'est pas auto mais en fait il est
nulle part alors évidemment tu regardes
sur les panneaux des agglomérations le
nom de commune il en français et en
créole donc littéralement le créole et
parentaux ou sur les publicités
quand tu sors de l'aja est arrivé à
pointe à pitre il ya une grand panneau
pour une boissons rafraîchissantes sans
alcool à base de jus concentré importés
bon ben le panneau il en créant ces
temps nous à l'entrée des abymes telle
pub pour vin mousseux le vin mousseux
2,7 en août façon depuis 2009
toi nous
mais concrètement tu vas trouver textos
en créole
tu trouves pas toi alors certes ans déjà
mais je me dire oui mais ti malo 23
comptent eux
avant on ne fait pas le droit de parler
maintenant on le craint et au bac 1
oui c'est vrai le que les taux bas et
évidemment à 20 effectivement on n'avait
pas le temps de parler maintenant des
taux bas j'ai entendu ça encore cette
année en octobre où on célèbre le mois
du créole en guadeloupe et effectivement
j'ai entendu ça le créole et aux marques
maintenant et j'ai entendu cette année
et j'en attends tu l'année dernière
aussi
oui trois primes allouées on est en
droit de le parler mais maintenant le
kloto bad alors et je n'ai entendu aussi
l'année d'avant je ne perds trois
continents nous on n'est pas le droit de
parler de ça fait dix ans que je me bats
en fait ça fait dix ans qu'on se dit ah
ouais c'est chouette
on n'est pas loin de parler maintenant
trois contes le creuset tout bas donc
c'est comme si tu vois le corps avancent
et puis au bout d'un moment ils
n'avancent plus mais c'est pas grave
c'est bon le real est au bac
et puis avant donc avant on avait lu
écouté la radio
le csm contre les droits de mon à l'eau
tu as écouté le match real tu mais bon
ça c'est plus mais tu as l'impression
que le grelle avancions avant bon tu
buvais pour le coup l'espagnol grâce à
la radio mais ça se fait plus mais bon
le creux de l'avant si tu vois avant on
avait des gens qui prenaient des coups
pendant l'hymne a écrit en créole mais
dans un taudis plus incroyable c'est pas
grave tu vois on prend trois conquêtes
au bac
alors évidemment il ya des gens qui se
battent pour faire des choses pour
sortir des dictionnaires pour faire des
ouvrages de grammaire pour essayer de
remonter une école mais collectivement
nous qu'est ce qu'on veut pour le real
ouvrons une parenthèse
vous avez fait au bas mot 12 ans
d'études un minimum entre 6 ans et 18
ans vous êtes à l'école certains d'entre
vous ont fait quinze peut-être dix sept
années d'études
je les vois là pendant ses douze ans
minimum vous avez fait site en anglais
l'oeuvre non collège les quatre années
de collège et les trois années de lycée
ça fait au moins c'est en anglais ok
lever la main si vous connaissez le mot
anglais pour dire pomme ok gars
gardaient la main levée gardait la main
levée si vous connaissez le mot anglais
vous dire qu au sol a déjà beaucoup
moins beaucoup moins de main levée vous
vous rendez compte
vous vous rendez compte que n'importe
quel gamin de 6 ans dominique voulu
demander qui sont radicaux au sol en
anglais ici vous répondre vous vous
rendez compte que du coup vous dès l'âge
de 6 ans vous avez exactement tout ce
qu'il faut pour discuter avec le gamin
de dominer que les yeux est mal de 0 à
10% en anglais et vous avez répondu et
où je vous dis vous sauriez pour ceux
qui ont baissé nam
comment audi corossol en anglais
vraiment la parenthèse obtenant ne la
ferme on pas tout de suite
imaginons un touristes anglophones viens
ici je sais me touristes anglophones je
sais c'est dur mais imaginons
motoriste anglophone vient ici il va sur
le marché est un fruit des kings
et là il se tourne vers vous et vous dis
excuse mais hésite ce sens ça
fermons la porte
non non on va en prendre un petit peu
dans un an pio c'est la preuve qu'ils
décident rires oui 2e royaume
c'est le roi qui décidera dans une
démocratie c'est fou ok et donc vous
allez avoir à décider qui s'occupe de
coopération régionale ici qui s'occupe
de l'enseignement supérieur et des
lycées ici qui s'occupe du développement
touristique ici et qui s'occupe du
développement économique ici vous allez
avoir à choisir un autre j'espère que
vous avez des idées très au clair sur ce
qu'on veut faire collectivement avec le
créole et là je ferme la parenthèse
d'autres résultat des courses on est au
21ème siècle
et moi je ne peux pas partir de l'écrit
pour fabriquer mon écrit à moi je suis
obligé de faire ce que les premiers
écrivains ont fait partir de la langue
orale prendre capter la substantifique
moëlle moelle penguins à la sorte
bref l'essentiel de ce qui est rare
beauté pour réussir à fabriquer la
langue écrite pour inventer la langue
créole écrite et quand je dis inventé je
devrais dire roi inventer de nouveaux
parce que le premier qui l'a fait le
premier qui l'a fait il a fait le trou
il a créé le texte donc on ne tenait pas
publiés du coup le deuxième il a dit le
roi faire et moi aujourd'hui j'arrive je
suis obligé de le waf et rome bon c'est
pas grave du coup ça me fait une
deuxième motivation est là je n'en ai
encore d'une autre chose c'est que il ya
une différence
mais alors une différence nette en
dehors de la tradition de la façon dont
on la route et la façon dont on croit
qu'on raconte
pour vous donner un exemple je vais vous
raconter quelque chose alors d'une
blague que je racontais mes potes je
vais pas te connaissent donc je vais
raconter l'histoire d'un fabrice et un
gay pas là donc ça vous régaler vos amis
hollandais empâté la team a donc émis
iphone safari wells fargo client optimal
tannoudji n'officie agissent voguer pas
à manhattan ou de niveau physique outils
question gay bah non c'est à dire que
mon fils il a pas de gamache est donc
bon avec moi car oui
attends attends grippe a c'est difficile
at elle dit j'ai fait pas bonne ou non
mais c'est à dire bretagne ont bien moi
donc un beau diable
non mais j'ai passé grâce à chaque arme
on a pu boire plus quoi faire
il offrait pas poignet on est là on la
désigne la partie à temps ou pour gay
pas là beaucoup moins
et non ça c'est comme ça que moi je
raconte quand je rencontre des trams et
poitiers et il ya la façon dont on croit
qu'on raconte doit par exemple à la
façon de ti fabrice fabsoul venu je te
dis pas si j'atteins dit jamais donné
beaucoup point de remonter la fin vous
savez beaucoup dit - la bunge et à dia
jeudi un débat sécuritaire d'honneur ça
c'est la façon petit fabrice on a aussi
la façon bostik messieurs et dames
arrivé à l'arrêt la pointe à journée
vous amène aussi fabrice fabrice taisne
yoshimi ce chemise à fabrice à bouaké
pas sinon c'est ea 7e à baie saint paul
gay pas fabrice hénon pantalon pas de
bébé pantalon patte de la famille s'en
faut à gué pas enfin oui cela nous
permet par ses avocats cela fabrice fois
non non non non non un poids certain
et donc ça c'est la façon bostik et
qu'est ce qu'on remarque avec ces deux
personnages c'est que d'une part c'est
du comics d'exagération et d'autres
encore ce sont des personnages qui sont
quand même issue des années 70 sur que
on croise pas vraiment de bostik de la
ou de nos jumeaux ou si peu
alors évidemment il s'agit pas de blâmer
les acteurs et les les auteurs qui ont
créé ces personnages d'une part il
fallait bien commencer quelque part
mais le souci c'est qu'à force de
n'avoir que ces représentations là de
notre façon de raconter dans nos têtes
du coup dès qu'on a envie de faire un
truc sérieux donc on a envie de raconter
quelque chose des ports autant tu vois
on peut faire pour le français tu
arrives tu fais une tête tu fais en
français tu vois parce qu'en fait c'est
sérieux et dans ta tête la
représentation du créole c'est le
comique c'est l'exagération etc et donc
du coup j'en porte l'autoroute a fourni
la langue la langue dominante quoi tu
vois là et résultat à force de ne pas
parler talent tu finis par ne plus être
capable de s'exprimer dans cette langue
et tu t'en vas pas contre ce mauvais pas
imaginez vous la mère de rose ou via web
loupe et voilà qu'on accompagne dans une
foire agricole qui se fait régulièrement
ici on l'a on accompagne dans une foire
agricole et là elle tombe sur une
entreprise qui fabrique du gros du
vinaigre à base de groseilles et détient
s'intéresse donc je demande au jeune
homme qui est là voilà la mère de rose
ou intéressés par ce que tu fais est ce
que tu pourrais lui expliqué en anglais
ou encore parce qu'elle parle pas
français
les matches mais on ne va pas les
problèmes et donc le gars comme un soin
dont vous proposez là où on refait cette
langue de boeuf c'est quand ma fille est
tombée thoniers
et là je vois je vois la consternation
sur le visage du jeune homme je vois la
tristesse de se rendre compte qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à expliquer quelque chose
qu'ils aiment ce quelque chose qui son
métier il n'arrive pas à l'expliquer en
créole donc si j'ai une chose à vous
demander c'est de faire l'effort réel
effort quand vous rentrez chez vous de
temps en temps de rater votre journée à
votre mari à votre épouse à vos enfants
racontez votre journée du début à la fin
en créole
et si le coeur vous en dit essayez de de
vérifier votre vocabulaire dans un
dictionnaire ou de vous poser des
questions tient cette locution là cette
façon de s'exprimer est ce que c'est
vraiment ma façon de parler parce qu'en
fait cette difficulté qu'on a à raconter
c'est quelque chose qui nous concerne
tous finalement on a tous à raconter
raconter c'est quoi c'est dû il s'est
passé ça ensuite il s'est passé ça use
ça use
donc ça c'est la structure de base de
raconter une histoire ou alors c'est
comme une recette de cuisine une recette
de cuisine en raconter les dombes
raymond d'abord tu fais ça si tu fais ça
expliquait sa raconter ça c'est déjà la
base de trouver comment raconte dans
notre langue qui est la nôtre une
planque authentique c'est à dire notre
personnel
là chacun notre langue personnel et donc
moi c'est ça que j'aurais envie de vous
demander parce que avec cette diversité
d'expressions là avec cette diversité de
façon de raconter c'est la diversité de
la langue qu'on apporte et cette
diversité de la langue
je pense qu'elle est nécessaire pour la
pluralité du monde